simone biles's boyfriend jonathan owens
shows his support as the gymnast
withdraws from more olympic events
where we perform we're expected to win
which it can kind of get a lot at times
because
we're so young with such a big amount of
pressure but i think we handle it very
well
on tuesday biles exited the gymnastics
team competition at the tokyo summer
olympics after the first rotation
and later decided to withdraw from the
individual competition
which is taking place on thursday biles
ever proud of team usa posted a photo
with her teammates holding up their
silver medals
her boyfriend nfl pro jonathan owens
slid into the comments to show his
support
writing i'm so proud of y'all owens who
plays safety for the houston texans
also took to his instagram story to
cheer his lady on
posting this video watching biles on tv
along with a series of hand clap emojis
i'm excited
but this isn't the first time owens has
publicly praised biles and her
impressive athleticism
back in june after watching her compete
he posted
this image calling out the quote amazing
experience
and writing quote it's so cool that i
get to watch you do what you love
and be the best at that i'm so proud of
you my little champ
and owens isn't alone biles has received
an
outpouring of support on social media
from her adoring celebrity fans
like michelle obama fellow olympian adam
rippon
and her former dancing with the stars
pro sasha farber
who spoke to et about bile's unrivaled
work ethic
i feel so much love for her she is such
a hard worker and i remember
you know being in the gym with her we
had so much fun but
there is just you know this proves that
she's human and you know it's such a
beautiful thing to see
it's been an intense week of competition
for the 24 year old olympic gold
medalist
after biles withdrew from the team
competition on tuesday
citing a medical issue it was announced
on wednesday
that she was also pulling out from the
individual competition
a statement on behalf of usa gymnastics
read quote
after further medical evaluation to
focus on her mental health
it has been announced that simone biles
is out of the all-around
the organization also praised bile's
decision and applauded her bravery in
prioritizing her well-being
physically i feel good i'm in shape
emotionally
that kind of varies on the time in the
moment you know on tuesday the gymnast
joined her fellow teammates for an
interview with the today show
where she opened up about the pressure
and stress that comes with competing at
the highest level
coming here to the olympics and being
the head
star of the olympics is not an easy feat
so we're just trying to take it one day
at a time and we'll see